あの見てわかると思うんですけど髪の毛がめっちゃんぱどるんですよ
ご覧ください思った部分的にも白い煙が入るんだねぐらいのちょっと明るさになってる
んですけども
なんだねぇ
もう
雷白くしたいなと思っちゃってやる最初に中田ついだけはやっぱ夏っぽく金髪にしよう
と思ってみんなで金髪にしたよね言ってたんですけど
面ともその時から僕ちょっとおかしかったのか何かもっともっともっと金髪にしたい
もっと明るくしてもっと明るくしてなんか coleridge した人ならわかると
思うんですけどもどんどん明るくしたくなっちゃうんですよね金髪
その明るさせ意識みたいに今度みんな金箔にしてどんどん加速しててみんなでこう金髪
金髪 bleach ブリーチハイブリッドハイブリッドホワイトデーチョコレートベ
リってこどんどん壁だけ恐れを食ってるとこうなってしまいました
うすって言って私はずですと今多分時点で1番髪の毛が明るい状況でございますどーん
もうここまで来たらいっそのことは白にしたいそういう感情が芽生えてしまいました北
中身わけなんですけど今まあシロッコがあるんですけども結局は金なんですよねぇねぇ
やっぱり黄色がちょっと残ってるんで結局これも金髪なんですよ聞いたが紛れもなく
スロで近いこういう状況だったらもう一度んだまっすぐにしちゃおうということで公開
こちら manic パリのヴァージン須藤ってやつ使いたいと思いませんじゃねぇ
金髪とか茶髪速
結構する人いると思うんですけども白や白ってすごくないか皆さんの悪口がじゃない
ですかとけど僕も人生のうちであのおじいちゃんになる前に1回考えてシロップしてみ
たいということでをはできたからもうやりましょう
だけ罰するでしようと思います来いよって現場ですねもう染めてきて髪が傷んでって
多分
色が落ちまくってるんでこの状況さらに真っ白にするためにどんな手段があるのかと
いいますと
一つね紫チャンプをしてどんどんちょっと白っぽく白っぽくしていく
僕これじゃあちょっとずつしておりましてでもう一個がグリーちおかなどいささか
blitz をする
マイカーがこちらに来パニックでも交通紫っぽいじゃないかなんでこれを得ると黄色み
が
抜けてもっと白に近づくらしいんですよというわけで多分今の僕の髪の毛
結構いい感じにしろが入ると思うんで人生で一度行ってみたら頭とか見ておきましろ
なぜかわかんないタブになると思うんですけどもやってみようと思いますよ
よしっちゅう月早速収めていこうと思いますよしここまで来るとね何が怖いって言うん
神時普通になってるんですよびっくりするぐらい考えが痛んでてもうね神ギア染められ
ないなって感じです
苦労中にはもう髪の毛が傷んでて本当にかわいそうかなければ愛着でタオルドライして
きました
果たしてこれに何の意味があるのでしょうかいややっぱ c ろい
こっから見てわかると思うんだけど本当にね白いんですよ
て惚れをもっと白くしていきますでも最近寒くなってきた感じで多分白もね合うと思う
んだ季節的にプーさん来いってやっぱり
白いちなみにこのマニックパニックなんですけどこれで髪の毛に色を入れるだけじゃ
なくて一応トリートアートなんだよねこれまでなんかトリートメント的な噂を聞いた
ことがあるよダークニメって書いてあるけど何からトリートメント的な効果があるって
中で誰かが言ってた気がする
この色ですからねこれがこの色ですからねこれより前に出てきますいや俺もう俺も知ら
んからなやるかね
ムラなくなりたいところがありますねこれでもせろ白い
はっすいろい
[音楽]
わかんないんですけども頑張ります何ですかねやっぱ金髪にはない難加工事例な感じが
白神にはありますね
部分的に見ると相当白くなっている気がしますパッと言えばなんと金髪の部分
t レベルになるちょっと不安なんだけど部分的にいる白いなくてはどこができる
でしょうか
いや待ってくださいんだけどちょっと待ってみましょうでああ
[音楽]
変わってねーからってザーッ思ったのかだったんですちょっと僕にはちょっとわかり
ません
完全に出ねぇなんか白っぽくなってますねてく白いな
えっ
白身いやいや本当は白神っていうのはもっと真っ直ぐなんですよ貴方弱いなぁまぁ度
弱いけどかなり集ね近づいたと思います
なんかねこれでもまだま月ロックなれるんじゃないかと思っちゃいます
やっ白いってもやっぱり白いぞ
白いとこれすごいぞ白毛であって白くねー
集合待って白いはやっぱり俺やっぱりすごいかもしれんこれ
白い何コレ白いナバスによってなんか金髪に見えたりするに見えたりするんですけど
いや白いなぁ嘘とででみて分かったと思うんですけども完全にしろですね
はシロエちろん白じゃないんですよだからもうちょっと多分紫シャンプーとかすると
もうちょっと
多分白身が出ると思うんで今後の僕の髪の毛に期待しててください
最後にみんなの反応を見ておりません
落ちるんですよね
me
別特になんかスタンスから多摩わかんないわかんないわかんなん
ああああああ
me あった